foreign
from Twitter this one's from natish
how can you thrive as the sole
minimalist in a family that believes in
maximalist principles
so stating your favorite color is not a
judgment about the value of other colors
and I find that to be really important
if your favorite color is blue and
everyone else in your family really
loves red
it doesn't mean that you're right and
they're wrong and they're wrong and
you're right it just means that you have
different preferences now it is true
that maybe your family would benefit
from having a more minimalist life they
would benefit from this preference but
forcing a preference on to someone
because it's like forcing your favorite
shirt onto someone yes you know what TK
might look great if I uh gave him the
blue or the purple shirt I was wearing a
few episodes ago for episode 400. he
might look great but if he doesn't feel
great in it then I'm forcing it on him
then we're both gonna feel bad because
now he dislikes it I dislike it and so I
want to point something out that often
happens in a scenario like this you have
a family especially if you live with the
family but it can be distant family who
lives elsewhere as well what happens is
we get annoyed by their preferences and
then my
default state is to then annoy them
further with my preferences and it
becomes this arms race of annoyance I'm
annoyed by you so I'm going to annoy you
back and now you're annoyed by me so
you're going to annoy me back there's
this constant escalation that is totally
unnecessary and so the best thing I've
ever done with respect to minimalism is
never proselytize it I'm not out there
saying hey look at me I'm a minimalist
and you should become a minimalist too
and here are the seven ways you can do
it here's how you get your certification
here are the things you should get rid
of here are the things you should buy to
organize here are the things that you
should declutter here are the things
going forward the brands that you should
have here's the car that I want you to
own here's the job you should have
because now I'm inflicting the other
people with my preferences creating
wounds in the relationship with my
preferences it's okay to have your
preferences without needing them them to
have your same preferences yeah you know
a lifestyle isn't really a lifestyle if
everyone else needs to live it in order
for me to be able to live a worldview
isn't really a world view if everyone in
the world needs to First have my view in
order for me to have it and so sometimes
when we find beliefs or practices or
strategies that work for us we treat it
like an MLM oh man I found something
that's really good it's gonna change my
life if my entire family Buys in and if
they don't all of a sudden this thing
that I'm bought into is actually empty
and worthless is that what you really
think of the things that you're doing if
the things you're doing can't work
unless everybody in your life Buys in
that's probably a clue that that thing
is worth abandoning the way it works is
you say I found something that makes me
a better me and I trust myself to work
out the details of living that out
fleshing that out in a world where
everyone else doesn't have to think the
same so for nitish
when we think about living with someone
or being friends with someone it doesn't
have to do with forcing them to be more
like me but
tolerating their preferences eventually
accepting their preferences
respecting their preferences unless
they're doing something that's harmful
obviously don't respect something that's
harmful but that's not what we're
talking about here and addition
eventually you can get to a point where
you actually appreciate
their differences the fact that they
enjoy somewhere later in the episode
we're going to go through Jordan's home
and I don't just tolerate the fact that
he has a completely different set of
tastes from me I don't even just respect
it I really appreciate how much joy he
gets from that or Professor Sean he has
this pin collection that he really gets
immense Joy from now for me if I wanted
to
to keep my preferences on him I said
well this is actually the only pin you
should use here it's this pilot
g207 this is the perfect pin any pin
besides this it's not minimalist I don't
sanction it and you're not allowed to
like it and what am I doing there I'm
extracting all of the joy that he gets
out of that
and the truth is while his pins would
get in the way for me they would be
clutter for me
he gets an immense benefit from them he
gets to experience it in a way that I
don't experience them instead of just
tolerating that I love that about his
experience with those and I wouldn't
want to deprive him of that yeah you
know when it comes to introducing
changes to your life and you're living
in a space where other people don't
think and act like you you have to start
in the short term by focusing on what's
within your locus of control while you
develop strategies for expanding your
sphere of influence but you never build
momentum you never get started you never
develop strength if you're always
thinking about other people right and so
if I live in a home where I'm committed
to minimalist principles and everyone
else is committed to maximalist
principles what's the space in that home
that I have some influence over and
maybe it's just one desk
despise not the day of Small Beginnings
right that desk is going to be the best
space in this house it's going to be the
most aesthetically pleasing it's going
to be the most minimalist space and
that's where I'm going to practice
working it out it's when we refuse to
cherish and value those small
opportunities that we lose the
opportunity to be people of influence
who can Inspire others that's what
generates the Curiosity when you can
focus on those small spaces you do have
control over and go all in rather than
fighting people over the whole house
they're never going to take you
seriously anyway they don't want to be
converted they don't want to have to
change every time you change let them
see your character as you work it out
within the context of what you have
influence over speaking of influence
since we've been talking about social
media clutter today
I've never been influenced by a social
media influencer uh oh however there are
a lot of influential people who have
influenced Me by not even trying to
influence me there are writers there are
people who are on social media with
large followings who influence me
without trying to force me into their
point of view and so when we're talking
to natish about being influential to the
people with maximalist principles in her
family what does that mean it means
setting an example that other people are
eager to follow because they see the
benefits of simplifying and their
benefits might be slightly different
from yours but it's so much more
compelling if I walk over I say wow that
desk seems so clean it seems so calm TK
where'd you get that from her or who
told you to do to to organize like that
then it opens up the door for the
conversation about living simple living
with less yeah absolutely man did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free